ja also ich habe mich ein bisschen
darüber geärgert dass jetzt oft so
gesagt wird inflation die reichen spüren
es ja gar nicht dass spüren nur die
armee auf der einen seite ist es schon
richtig also als jemand der jetzt selbst
viel geld hat spricht natürlich nicht so
wenn die lebensmittelpreise steigen oder
auch die heizkosten das ist richtig aber
vergesst die sparer dich ja es gibt in
deutschland
ich glaube sechzig millionen oder noch
mehr verträge für lebensversicherungen
ja die leute die bis jetzt ausgezahlt
bekommen ja keine andere zum beispiel
ich habe einen teil von meinem geld ich
habe viele aktien und immobilien da ist
mir nicht so betroffen aber in anleihen
zum beispiel da gibt es heute ein
prozent vielleicht und wenn ich dagegen
neun prozent inflation hat ja dann kann
ich mir ausrechnen was es dann bedeutet
das heißt der sparer der wird im moment
einfach vergessen und sparer sind
natürlich jetzt die armen in dem sinn
weniger einfach weil sie nicht so viel
haben was sie sparen können deswegen
sage ich ja die armen sind betroffen
natürlich sehr stark von den heizkosten
von was weiß ich ja aber anders sind
betroffenen besonders die sparkassen
betroffen weil es ist ja eine enteignung
was da stattfindet auf dem weg und das
ist mein thema heute ja da ist natürlich
die erste frage haben sie eigentlich
einen pool na ja wohl allein also da
haben sie schon mal kein problem mit den
sparmaßnahmen im energiesparen der
regierung weil das ist ja jetzt auch
nicht mehr möglich sein eigenen pool
soll nicht mehr möglich sein so
wiesbaden es möglich heiß baden kalt
schwindelig aber was würden sie
vorschlagen also ihr lösungsvorschlag an
die regierung
leider muss man sagen dass es manche
probleme gibt für die es keine rasche
lösung gibt ja das wird das sagen
politiker natürlich nicht gern und es
ist auch kein großer trost für die
bürger aber ein hauptpunkt von der
inflation ist ja angerichtet durch die
zentralbanken ja durch die
niedrigzinspolitik was sie die ganzen
jahre gemacht haben und klar das ist
jetzt als politiker diese haltung die
man haben kann wir können ja nichts dran
machen aber ist auch ein bisschen
unehrlich den leuten zu sagen wir können
die ganzen folgen der inflation mit
immer mehr staatsgeld sozusagen dann
beseitigen das wird am ende nicht
möglich sein so das würde ich sogar
teilen also wir können nicht die summen
die wir jetzt draufzahlen komplett
ausgleichen wir konzentrieren uns darauf
dass diejenigen die am wenigsten haben
wenig das den ausgleich kriegen weil für
die geht's ans eingemachte warm eine
zahl zu nennen wir haben letztes jahr um
die 70 milliarden euro ausgegeben für
fossile energieimporte dieses jahr
werden 150 milliarden sein das sind 80
milliarden mehr sind zwei prozent des
bruttoinlandsprodukts das ist einfach
wohlstandsverlust und der geht nächstes
jahr weiter aber falls spielen wären
eigentlich unseren status als starke mit
wir brauchen in den mittel mittelschicht
ist ja eigentlich das was wir brauchen
eine starke mittelschicht wie stark
verspielen wir dass die gefahr ist schon
da das wir substanziell verlieren in den
nächsten jahren nicht nur in diesem
einen wintern deswegen sind maßnahmen
auf der einen seite der entlastung
notwendig aber auf der anderen seite
eben auch innovation kreativität
handwerk und wer später noch hinzu also
das war auch anpacken also es wird auch
eine kraftakt leistung notwendig seien
das einzig gute daran die situation ist
wenn man in der krise ist dass man
schnell handeln muss man kreativ sein
werden wir auch gezwungen sein schneller
manche prozesse zu beschleunigen
hoffentlich auch digitalisierung
übrigens da sind wir nämlich auch nicht
besonders guten deutschland coburger wie
sieht es bei ihnen aus man sagt jetzt
schon laut studien da 60 prozent nicht
meine lage sind rücklagen zu bilden wie
sieht es bei ihnen aus können sie etwas
zurück legen aktuell noch also es ist
natürlich so dass
die gronauer krise viele bereiche
getroffen hat aber ich kann sagen
durch mein handwerk dass das handwerk
ziemlich krisensicher ist klar sind
unsichere zeiten im moment aber ich
würde trotzdem sagen beim handwerk das
wird immer gebraucht und das wird
eigentlich täglich in anspruch genommen
würde ich behaupten das ist schon
ziemlich krisensicher und ich würde mich
auch immer viel handwerk entscheiden
weil sie im aktuell noch keiner not und
sagen man kann auch genug sparen in
deutschland also man kann immer was zur
seite legen weil man natürlich
auch nie weiß was die zukunft bringen
das ist klar aber ich würde trotzdem
behaupten dass man
schon gewisse sicherheit bietet
gerne etwas ja noch ganz spannend ist
was ich ganz spannend fand und mir auch
aufgeschrieben untere einkommen hat vier
empfänger müssen keine gas umlage zahlen
rentner und geringverdiener aber schon
ist das eigentlich fair
die frage wie rentnerinnen und rentner
jetzt auch noch mal im entlastungspaket
drei oder vielleicht auch wenn das noch
kommt auch entlastet werden müssen
stellt sich in der tat weil die sind in
den ersten paketen nicht dran gewesen
das war so das muss man auch zugeben auf
der anderen seite gab es einen
rentenerhöhungen von sechs prozent die
haben jetzt erstmal auf die
arbeitnehmerinnen nicht gekriegt in dem
fall aber sie haben die frage wo sie in
punkt treffen den wir beantworten müssen
ich möchte noch mal auf das thema
altersvorsorge kommen haben weil wir
haben jahrelang auch die politik gesagt
du musst auch privat fürs alter
vorsorgen die meisten menschen wissen
dass auch die haben dann angesparten in
irgendeiner form ich gebe zu die
deutschen nicht so besonders clever
meistens ja aber drei viertel von dem
geld das liegt so auf tagesgeldkonten
sparbüchern in lebensversicherungen und
die sind alle nicht inflationsgeschützt
und das wird massiv entwertet ich glaube
da haben sich viele noch gar keine
gedanken drüber gemacht aber die aktien
sind jetzt zum beispiel auch zum
beispiel es gerade im freien fall und
auch nicht inflationär
aktien sind schon wenn man längeren
zeitraum anguckt ehren inflationsschutz
genau wie immobilien aber das haben ja
die meisten deutschen nicht die meisten
deutschen treffer die haben ihr geld
halt auf sparbücher tagesgeld konten und
lebensversicherung ja und das wird
massiv entwertet das heißt da geht die
gesamte altersvorsorge kaputt und das
ist ja noch mal eine andere dimension
ob ich sage ich muss jetzt mal ein
winter irgendwo höhere heizkosten oder
sowas auch schlimmes oder dann die frage
meine ganze altersvorsorge war falsch
für die katz wenn wir noch ein paar
jahre die inflation haben also nummer
und das hatten auch noch nicht also wir
hatten wir vor 20 jahren war die
inflation genau so hoch wie jetzt ja
1981 stand man auch so 48 prozent aber
damals gab es elf prozent für eine
bundesanleihe heute ist ein prozent das
ist auch der große unterschied deswegen
das hatten wir noch nie das da auf dem
weg einer enteignung der leute
stattfindet und die die altersvorsorge
von der ganzen generation wenn das so
weitergeht mit der inflation mit ein
paar jahre zerstört wird letztlich in
der tat kann man auch in dem fall der
ampel man kann sie für vieles
verantwortlich machen aber ich glaube
für die aktuelle inflation nicht oder
wenn überhaupt nur zu ganz gering teilen
aber ich glaube es zeigt sich nochmal
auch was für ein historischer fehler ist
von angela merkel gewesen ist bei der
neubesetzung
der spitzenposition der europäischen
zentralbank nämlich den
präsidentenposten sich nicht gegen emana
makoun durchgesetzt zu haben sondern da
den kürzeren gezogen zu haben ja wir
sind die größte volkswirtschaft als
deutschland in europa es gibt eine
hervorragende wie ich finde tradition
geldpolitische tradition der bundesbank
die extrem auf stabilität gesetzt hat
und wenn man aber man schaut die 20
jahre euro die wir jetzt haben dann war
noch nie ein deutscher oder eine
deutsche präsident dieser europäischen
zentralbank es war einmal einer da das
gut gemacht er musste aber dann aus
verschiedenen gründen seiner amtszeit
zur hälfte abtreten dann war es zweimal
ein franzose und ein italiener alles
länder die aus der erfahrung und aus der
historie heraus er nicht so für eine
starke und sehr strikte geldpolitik
geworben haben oder dass in ihrer
tradition haben sondern ich immer mit
inflation gelebt haben das rächt sich
jetzt auf dramatische weise und ich kann
nur appellieren ich glaube die ampel in
ihrer jetzigen zusammensetzung wird ist
glaube ich immer auf sieben jahre
gewählt die chefin der europäischen
zentralbank wird es möglicherweise nicht
mehr erleben diese ampel zumindest nicht
vielleicht gibt es auch keine weitere
was auch immer aber die aktuelle
bundesregierung nicht aber der appell
glaube ich kann nur sein für die nächste
bundesregierung alles dafür zu tun dass
der nächste ezb-chef oder die nächste
ezb-chef hin auf jeden fall aus
deutschland kommt aus der tradition der
bundesbank nicht umsonst haben schon
drei top geldpolitiker in der ezb
hingeschmissen drei deutsche weil sie es
nicht mehr ausgehalten haben
das ist zukunftsmusik und wäre schön
wenn es so wird aber eine frage habe ich
noch ganz konkret in herne check.de
robert habeck also der wirtschaftsseite
heute ja auch davor gewarnt dass man den
sozialen frieden zusammenhalten muss und
in frieden ist die politik sich dem
bewusst wie groß der soziale sprengstoff
eigentlich auch gerade in diesem land
ist wenn menschen angst haben ihr gas
nicht mehr zahlen zu können ihre mieten
ist man sich da gewann im bundestag so
der bundeskanzler hat er gesagt you
never walk alone also du bleibst nicht
alleine wir lassen dich nicht allein wir
schaffen das da kriegt man als bürger
immer fast an
das würde das so sagen man kann sich
darauf verlassen dass wir das im auge
haben
aber was wir auch sagen sollten ehrlich
ist dass wir nicht wissen wie die
entwicklung der nächsten jahre sein wird
allerdings gibt es eine positive
entwicklung die wir sehen können glaube
ich werden möglicherweise in der
rezession kommen zeitnah das heißt aber
nicht zwangsläufig dass der arbeitsmarkt
das ist eine neue situation in
deutschland dass der arbeitsmarkt schwer
getroffen sein wird schlichtweg weil wir
ehrlich gesagt ein arbeitskräftemangel
haben
die frage ist auch genau wie die
inflation kompensiert wird über
lohnsteigerungen aber was eher nicht zu
erwarten ist ist dass wir jetzt in der
phase der massenarbeitslosigkeit
zurückkehren die wir schon mal hatten
vor 20 jahren selbst wenn wir jetzt bei
der wachstumsrate ins minus gehen glaube
ich können wir da zumindest den leuten
sicherheit in der arbeit weitestgehend
versprechen und das ist ja schon mal was